well the the mosfer the flagship of the
Black Sea Fleet we know has been damaged
and we know it's effectively been
removed from from the fight we're
getting reports it's on his way probably
to Sebastopol
um for probably what's major repairs
whether it's a fire whether it's been
hit by Ukrainian missiles I don't think
we know yet my senses is probably
Ukrainian missiles and if that's the
case it's pretty totemic from the
Ukrainian Point why do you think that's
why is that the sense that you're
getting out of it um I think because of
the the nature of the way the reporting
came in I think if there was a fire it'd
be quite difficult for the ukrainians to
know to immediately then claim as a
missile strike
um so so I think more on balance
probably it's a Ukrainian strike he said
you think it's on its way back to
sevastava Sebastopol that's where it was
last seen on the 7th of April I mean
what do we know so far about its
condition and how important this is
um I think we know there's been a major
fire and therefore is probably now out
of action I think as far as Russia is
concerned and that's denied it uh some
significant command and control and
probably air defense it's quite an old
ship it was commissioned some 40 years
ago but I think its removal says if it
has been hit by Ukrainian missiles it
says more about Ukrainian capability
it's it's a pretty good thing for them
to have done really quite ingenious
um it denies if you like Russia the
ability to get close to the to the to
the coast so it'll make them stand off a
bit and it'll make them think about
amphibious operations in the future okay
so this um assault now away from this
attack the assault that we're waiting
for from the Russians do we know when
it's happening if it's happening what's
the state of play there so I think what
we're seeing and have seen over the past
few days perhaps a week or so is Russia
seeking to build forces to really get
disproportionate forces compared to the
ukrainians out in the East we know that
Mario poll is UN still under significant
pressure will probably fall within the
next week that will allow troops from
Mario Pole to start to go North to
support that offensive from the East
Russia positioning really to have
disproportionate Force to attack those
well-dugging Ukrainian troops in the
East the challenge really from a
Ukrainian point of view and from a
western point of view is can they
resupply can they get the right weapons
and equipment into these to give
ukrainians the best chance of keeping
Russia out it's a real battle of
logistics and I think that battle is
going to set the tone antenna of success
in the campaign probably over the next
month or so okay Phil thank you so much